soare just now we were talking about why
do we introduce the parameter and I gave
you an explanation for it the really
cool thing about it is once you know
what the parameter is on a problem what
it means you're like oh this is cool
it's a new geometric way to look at a
parabola to understand it okay but you
can do more cool stuff with the
parameter and we're going to spend the
rest of this topic exploring that chords
on one of the objects that we're
interested in to make sure we know what
we're talking about let's think about
circles cuz that's where we've met
chords already what is a chord on a
circle what's the definition of a chord
okay so I'm gonna be a little more
specific than a line a court has a
beginning and an end it doesn't just go
on forever so that has a more technical
native satyr than I it's an interval so
a chord is an interval that connects two
points on the circle that's it once you
have that definition it's exactly the
same for a parabola which is kind of
nice right so you pick two points any
two points you like here and here let's
call these guys say P and Q and the
interval joining these is a chord right
so here's a chord you get a chord you
get a chord everyone gets a chord that's
all we're talking about okay now then it
becomes a natural question to ask well
what is the equation of said chord well
we have two points on the parabola
I can now define them in terms of a
single number right before I would have
had to have like you know the
x-coordinate explored a y-coordinate and
know them independently but now I know
them together so if this is our regular
locus definition of a parabola right
then I can say any point on the parabola
is in the form now do you remember what
were the parametric equations I gave you
right at the beginning 288 a squared -
80 a T squared okay which sounds to spit
suspiciously like 2 pi R PI R squared
which it anyway so you've got these two
coordinates here for any arbitrary point
let's say at Point P
capital P for the sake of convenience
let's call its coordinates to a
lowercase P a lowercase P squared so in
this case the particular parameter I'm
using is little P so for this guy over
here if we have a point capital Q how
about what a novel idea I call its
coordinates to aq a you square okay so
what I've got is I've used the
parametric equations to write the
coordinates in parametric form okay and
now you've just got two points so you
can use 2.4 now that's a worker the
equation of the chord right so equation
of chord PQ okay what's it going to look
like well the equation of a two point
sort of line thing looks like this right
y minus y1 X minus x1 let's see let's
call this one x1 y1 so that would make
this up here and this down here is that
okay what are you going to get on the
right hand side yep so instead of Y
minus y1 it'll be y2 y2 minus y1 how's
that look is that okay all divided
through by x2 minus x1
hey going just a substitution yeah X on
y1 x2 y2 now it's very nice to see all
of this stuff is gonna cancel out one or
all of it but a lot of stuff right for
example on the right hand side what the
easy stuff can you see that will cancel
the A's are going to go right this a
which is a common factor in the top will
also be a common factor down the bottom
that's good what else can I get rid of
okay so on the top I'm gonna have to
rewrite this because too much stuff is
in my brain right now q minus P Q plus P
is difference of squares on the
numerator and on the denominator there's
still a two hanging around and then
there's the Q minus P that Shion
suggested I can't
I can write I might as well write the
left hand side because I'm about to
reuse it okay so cancel cancel this is
looking better already
now this guy over here on the right hand
side remember where it came from
where it came from Wars y 2 minus y 1 on
X 2 minus X 1 what is that
that's gradient right the two point
formulas gradient baked into it and so
therefore since I'm going to get the
equation of a line and the right-hand
side is the gradient I kind of might as
well leave it like that right if I can
leave the gradient there then it's gonna
be easy to write this in like y equals
MX plus B form which is like a useful
form right so this guy on the right hand
side I'm gonna leave this as 1/2 P plus
Q that's all that gets left on the right
hand side do you agree
while I'm at it I will multiply both
sides by this okay so that leaves me
with X minus P how's that look is that
okay
as your brain going so I have just
reaching the right side a teeny bit and
then I've multiplied both sides by this
denominator so far so good now if you
have a look carefully look carefully on
the right hand side I have got my M X
right there
do you see that you see there are no
more X terms anywhere so therefore I can
write y equals M that's M fair times X
and I'm expecting a plus B a plus B but
look the plus B is made of two things
there's this stuff times that and then
there is this guy right so I'm going to
probably have to add it to both sides
and get Y as the subject do you agree so
let's do this
these last two pieces on this side I'm
going to have minus 1/2 P plus Q times 2
AP UK with that you see where I got that
from through the expansion of the
brackets and then I've got an a P
squared there
brain doing okay can I cancel some stuff
what can I cancel yep fantastic cancel
cancel that's good what else can I get
rid of what what's what's what happens
when I expand this that's gonna be minus
ap squared whole look I have a plus AP
squared there that's convenient and then
I'll be left with minus a P Q you see
that so that'll be left behind so what
this leave me with is this there's the M
X and then here is the B put that guy in
a box that is the equation of a chord
okay so if you know two points and you
know what their gradients are P and Q
then you can state what the equation of
the chord is between